we have got the new home pod but is it
worth 300 compared to spending 200 on
two homepod Minis and how does it sound
compared to the original homepod well
today I will let you guys hear for
yourselves the difference in volume and
sound quality with three different
tracks using our high-end 850 dollar
microphone setup not only that but I'm
gonna run a sound frequency analyzer so
you guys can visually see the difference
in the base the mids and the highs along
with volume now the weird thing about
the new home pod is that they removed
two of the tweeters that were there
previously and the weight is also lower
as well so technically they made it
lower quality it has an Apple Watch chip
in there an older one so we'll see how
it sounds now on the back you guys could
see that the cable is now removable
which is really nice in case it gets
messed up so they're trying to save some
money but the other weird thing is that
they dropped the price by 50 bucks
compared to the original while making it
less nice I guess in a way or cheaper to
build but the original was also on sale
for 300 bucks all the time so you guys
see at the top here now we have the
volume buttons ingrained in here and
it's a little bit concave so I don't
know what other cost reductions came
into play but now let's go ahead and
start listening to the differences we
are going to start out with the classic
Max Tech song and we're going to cycle
between all three of these multiple
times so you guys can hear the
difference
[Music]
let's take this
all right guys so that first one was a
loudness test and boy was there a
difference the homepod minis that are
paired up reached 78 decibels the
original homepod reached 84 and it's a
lot louder but the new homepod actually
reached 86 consistently at the loud part
and it was the only one that gave me a
loud warning on my Apple watch so
there's a big difference now I'm gonna
make them all the same volume so you
guys can listen to the sound quality
differences
is
[Music]
painkillers
foreign
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and with that I'm
actually going to be comparing the new
homepod to the echo studio and the
Google Nest their heists and one so make
sure you guys are subscribed now I think
that the homepod minis were the most
balanced in terms of lows mids and highs
now I do wish they had more low end base
the original home but actually had the
most base it was a little bit boomy it
dug really low though whereas the new
home pod the highs really stand out
they're brighter and the mids are pushed
up as well so I feel like the best
balance are these but they do not have
that amazing bass so now let's go ahead
and switch to our next track
foreign
[Music]
so for this one I have to say that I
prefer the original homepod uh this is
where the minis just couldn't keep up
with their single drivers everything
sounded very mushed together not bad but
the new home pod the highs really stood
out into me personally a little bit too
much but now let's go ahead and listen
to this Rock track that makes it much
more difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
and for this one you guys let me know
your thoughts but I have to say that the
original homepod sounded the best that
is crazy and I don't even own this this
is vadims uh the new home pod while it
does sound really good I think the highs
just stand out a little bit too much and
you can EQ that in the Apple music app
but if you airPlay to it those don't
come into effect now this is where the
minis uh the ones that I actually own
Sound by far the worst close to an
Amazon Echo cheap speaker at least
getting there because there's too many
frequencies happening now as for the
frequency analysis I set all them to the
same volume here we have the homepod one
the homepod 2 and the mini homepods now
I tried to layer these together in
Photoshop and shift the colors a little
bit with opacity but it's not great but
what you can see is that the homepod 2
has much more Bass Down Low they start
to kick up at 40 Hertz but the homepod 2
is much louder in that area all the way
up to around 100 where they meet now
here it's hard to tell because they flip
and the colors are too similar so let me
go back to this original the homepod one
at around 160 is quite a bit louder than
the homepod 2. the same thing goes in
the mids over here the homepod original
is louder and in the 500s leading up to
a thousand the original homepod is
louder but when it comes to high
frequencies the homepod 2 has a lot more
Sparkle it's a lot more bright as for
The homepod Minis right here you guys
see how much less bass you have it
doesn't really start to kick up until
around 60 70 Hertz and even then the
base is so much lower than the homepod
2. now around 160 they meet all the way
up through around 400 or so and then the
minis start to dip back down lower now
around a thousand to 1500 they're fairly
similar but the minis have a dip over
here meet back up about two two and a
half and then in the high end the home
pod 2 has a lot more Sparkle the highs
really stand out so the minis are much
more flat across the board and then they
lack on a base compared to the homepod
2. with all that said let's answer the
original question should you buy the new
home pod or get two homepod Minis and is
this better than the original well I
think if you can afford it go with this
homepod it's way louder and lay later
down the line if you have some more cash
you can add another one the minis are
nice they sound pretty decent but if you
play them at loud volumes they don't get
loud and the sound quality goes down
which here for this quality test I did
not Max them out they're at 90 percent
um and the original homepod if you have
one of those I would say Do not upgrade
if you can buy a used second one on the
market now that these new ones come down
the prices will go down just buy a used
one with that setting this thing up it
took a lot longer than the original one
probably because it has slower Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth and I just don't know if it's
worth upgrading or buying new ones over
good price you know still good quality
older one so that is my opinion you guys
let me know your thoughts and make sure
you guys subscribe above to see the
comparison with The Echo studio and the
Google Nest check out one of those
videos right over there and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign